CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS HERE WITH
DETAILS ON A WARNING TO ONE OF
THE MAJOR FIGURES INVOLVED.
>> A FEDERAL JUDGE WARNED
MICHAEL AVENATTI TODAY, THE
LAWYER FOR FILM ACTRESS STORMY
DANIELS THAT HE WILL NEED TO
STOP HIS PUBLICITY TOUR IF HE
WANTS TO CONTINUE PARTICIPATING
IN THE CASE.
AS HE ENTERED THE COURTHOUSE,
MICHAEL COHEN DID NOT TALK TO
REPORTERS.
INSIDE, HIS LAWYER ARGUED THAT
THE RELEASE OF BANK RECORDS
AMOUNTED TO QUOTE A DRIVE-BY
SHOOTING OF HIS CLIENTS RIGHTS."
HE SUGGESTED THE TEAM IS
ILLEGALLY LEAKING RECORDED
CONVERSATIONS CONNECTED TO
DANIELS, AND WHILE THERE IS NO
INDEPENDENT EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THE CLAIM, OF A NAUGHTY TOLD
THEM THE REPORT SHOULD BE
RELEASED SO THE PUBLIC CAN
DECIDE.
>> THEIR IMPORTANCE RELATED TO
THE PRESIDENT, AND WHAT HE KNEW,
WHEN HE KNEW IT AND WHAT HE DID
AS IT RELATES TO CONSPIRING WITH
MICHAEL COHEN TO COMMIT ONE OR
MORE POTENTIAL CRIMES.
>> OF THE FEDERAL JUDGE SET A